meThe we're on it is the new slogan in
South Dakota it's a new campaign to
address a serious problem in that state
but the slogan meth were on it has a lot
of people scratching their heads take a
look at how it's used I'm on it I'm on
it too so am I so am I so Governor
Christie gnome came up with that slogan
working with an ad agency meth were on
it the way she means it is we as a state
recognize there's a problem and we're on
that problem everyone in our community
is tackling it but critics say this is
probably not the best way to get that
message across and it's probably not
gonna help people kick the habit so
Twitter had a field day with this one
calling the slogan tone-deaf failed
attempt at being clever but here's the
thing
the governor says look this is a giant
success you know we're not stupid we
knew you would make jokes about this but
the point was to have you talking about
it I you then we're talking about it
right here we're talking at the table
but the double meaning I think is
interesting because it shows anybody can
get hooked yes
regular people that you all know and to
show that they're on the case I actually
when I first saw it it made me wince a
little bit to like I don't like it but
the more you think about it the more I
think it makes a lot of sense yeah
talking maybe not in the poster form but
in the PSA well the important thing is
break it down like the important thing
into the end is that people are
conscious of it and know where that more
needs to be it's a serious serious it's
a big deal for dying